bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france le gouvernement
italien assoupli donc les lois anti
migrants adoptée il ya quelques 16 mois
par le leader de l'extrême droite matteo
salvini alors ministre de l'intérieur
qu'est ce qui va changer concrètement
alors concrètement le premier intérêt
qu'il va y avoir c'est que le flux
migratoires ne sera plus aussi limité
c'est à dire que les ong les toutes les
organisations de méditerranée ont rompu
auquel cas s'il rentre dans les eaux
territoriales italiennes une une amende
beaucoup plus restreinte elle était de 1
1 million jusqu'à un million avant
maintenant c'est seulement cinquante
mille euros
et puis dans un deuxième temps c'est
surtout à l'intérieur du pays que la
transformation se fait puisque avant les
migrants arrivant en italie ne pouvait
pas facilement obtenir des papiers pour
pouvoir commencer à s'insérer alors
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple la nouvelle
loi permettra de transformer la permis
de sept jours en permis de travail ce
qui permettra donc aux migrants d'avoir
une plus grande facilité de s'intégrer à
l'intérieur du territoire et dans un
deuxième point aussi le renvoi de ces
migrants dans leur pays d'origine sera
beaucoup plus compliqué puisque s'il ya
un risque de torture pour ces personnes
et on a eu plusieurs fois des cas de
témoignages de personnes qui avaient des
tortures en libye par exemple eh bien si
on considère que ces personnes ces
familles ou un risque et bien justement
elles ne pourront pas être renvoyés dans
leur coin ce qu'on doit ce genre de
changement de doctrine migratoire en
italie aujourd'hui ce que c'est le
résultat de nos de négociation d'un
politique au sein de la coalition
gouvernementale qui réunit on appelle le
mouvement 5 étoiles et le parti
démocrate ou bien est ce une réponse aux
aspirations aujourd'hui des italiens
alors il ya plusieurs cas autour de ça
bien sûr c'est une grande victoire du
parti démocrate qui démonte la loi de
matteo salvini qui avait été accepté par
le mouvement 5 étoiles qui aujourd'hui
le mouvement 5 et paul vote contre cette
loi
donc c'est une grande victoire du parti
démocrate d'un point de vue politique
d'un point de vue après de l'aspiration
des italiens c'est un peu plus compliqué
puisqu'on n'a pas une élection très
clair actuellement au niveau national
vous pourriez nous donner une réponse
mais on va dire que c'est aussi dans le
mouvement de ce que voulait le parti
démocrate c'est à dire une loi qui est
beaucoup plus forte en interne et en
interne aussi sur tout ce qui pourrait
être la criminalité en italie
d'une façon aussi de limiter justement
le travail au noir ou la clandestinité
de ces personnes puisqu'ils pourront
plus facilement avoir le droit et
l'accès au travail à présent justement
la loi de matteo salvini été très
contesté pour nos stars c'est à dire une
fois le million rentrer sur le
territoire et ce malgré la rigueur du
décret de mathieu flamini et bien ces
migrants se retrouvaient généralement à
travailler au noir en étant exploités
généralement et donc par ce système on
va changer réorienter autrement
justement l'aspect autour de ces
personnes qui vont entrer sur le
territoire et changer de doctrine
qu'est ce que ça dit aussi de la place
de matteo salvini sur l'échiquier
politique italien aujourd'hui rom1
tourner la page selvini alors la
saucisse est assez complexe à voir on va
dire que l'extrême droite actuellement
en italie restent puissantes mais on
voit d'autres mouvements à l'intérieur
de cette extrême droite il ya un an
matteo salvini était une évidence comme
leader de l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui il ya deux autres personnes
qui montent à côté de lui giorgia meloni
et son allié de toujours mais qui gagne
chaque jour un peu plus haut niveau de
l'électorat
et puis même à l'intérieur de la ligue
ou mettre sa ligne était le seul
dominant il ya un an maintenant il ya
d'autres figures qui reviennent perçu
peut-être par l'électorat comme un peu
plus sérieuse où nous organiser comme
par exemple le président de la région
vénétie
monsieur zahia qui a obtenu un
plébiscite dans sa région avec plus de
70% des votes en sa faveur
donc maintenant salvini existe encore
aujourd'hui l'un des concurrents dans sa
catégorie
et pour le chef du gouvernement actuel
je sais pas quand est-ce que c'est une
prise de risques cette nouvelle un
politique migratoire
alors là bien entendu pour monsieur
compter tout le monde attend de voir
pourquoi il accepte ça pourquoi il
décide de faire ça et surtout comment
va-t-il se placer pour les prochaines
élections
giuseppe comté est très apprécié par les
italiens actuellement général mais il
n'a toujours pas de partie il n'a
toujours pas on va dire de placement
politique réelle
il reste un peu sans un peu au mur et
donc tout le monde attend un petit peu
surtout ce choix ce qui peut faire est
ce que monsieur comté va se décider à
entrer dans le mouvement 5 étoiles au
parti démocrate sont des centres partie
donc on verra aussi par la suite celui
là mais c'est encore une inconnue
l'italie a multiplié ces derniers mois
ses appels à une répartition obligatoire
des migrants entre les différents pays
membres de l'union européenne
est ce qu'aujourd'hui sa révision des
lois migratoires peut avoir une
incidence sur l'union européenne
et laquelle bien sûr dès l'instant où
les migrants qui rentreraient sur le
territoire italien obtiendrait plus
rapidement a permis de séjour et un
permis de travail comme le veut séoul
est prêt après les accords qu'on
pourrait y avoir avec les autres pays la
répartition pour être aussi peu rapide
un c'est un des grands problèmes qu'il
ya eu en italie on est derniers mois
surtout quand on est et où les centres
de répartition et les centres d'accueil
n'arrive pas à gérer toutes ces
personnes qui restent enfermés pendant
plusieurs mois généralement l'intérieur
donc l'objectif bien sûr de se
déstresser aussi d'accélérer la
manoeuvre pour une répartition plus
simple et plus rapide
après il faudra bien sûr l'accord des
autres pays il faut rappeler bruxelles
fasse des choix et il faudra qu'une
italie cependant est alors comment
réagissent les italiens fin c'est un
nouvelle politique migratoire dans
l'ensemble là aussi c'est une loi qui
est beaucoup plus complexe parce que on
parle bien sûr de la semaine migratoire
de ce décret sécurité mais il est
tellement con si un décret sur le
territoire national puisque au delà de
la cité justement migrants il ya
énormément de loi par rapport à des
contrôles à l'intérieur du pays par
rapport à la criminalité le trafic de
drogue la protection de la vie privée
les personnes
il ya aussi dans cet ensemble de pâques
et un paquet sécurité qui ne me regarde
pas uniquement la méditerranée ils
regardent aussi territoire on verra son
application par la suite il ya des lois
importantes justement par rapport à des
cas de travail au noir ou alors à des
cadres de raquettes qu'il pouvait y
avoir des personnes qui vont normalement
par ce nouveau décret est assez limité
on verra la pâte
il ya mais techniquement il n'est pas
seulement pour les migrants selon ce
décret matteo salvini bien sûr le
critique pour cette partie mais il ya
toute une série de lois qui va encore
renforcer la justice par rapport à la
prime qualité et par exemple à la mafia
avait encore plus de risques pour les
personnes qui aiderait les personnes en
prison actuellement
merci à beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne fabien
beau enseignant à l'université de turin
on évoquait donc avec vous la nouvelle
politique migratoire italienne